500 000 !
Salut, on vient de passer les 500 000 abonnés sur la chaîne.
Vous êtes 500 000, ici à regarder les vidéos et à m'avoir rejoint.
C'est assez vertigineux.
Ça fait deux jours et on est même exactement à 512 268 !
Merci, juste merci beaucoup !
Quand j'ai réfléchi à la vidéo qu'on allait faire pour fêter ça
-parce que autant vous le dire, y avait rien de prévu, c'est arrivé beaucoup trop vite-
je pensais que ça arriverait, les 500 000 abonnés, peut-être au mois de septembre/octobre/novembre...
Là, j'ai été un petit peu pris de court.
Au tout début je me suis dit : "je vais me forcer à regarder mes anciennes vidéos et je vais me filmer et le commenter en même temps".
Et je me suis vraiment demandé s'il y avait un intérêt à faire ça.
J'en n'ai pas réellement trouvé.
Il y a plus de 400 vidéos sur cette chaîne que j'ai lancée le 1er janvier 2016.
D'ailleurs si des fois vous vous demandez si j'ai parlé d'un sujet particulier,
tapez dans la barre des recherches Google: "Olicard" suivi du sujet que vous cherchez
pour voir si il n'y a pas une vidéo déjà dessus.
Et bref... Jeudi soir dans mon lit, quand on a passé le cap des 500 000 personnes sur cette chaîne,
j'ai eu une idée, vous faire un test avec 6 personnes, 5-6 personnes
dont une personne ment et vous devez retrouver qui est la personne qui ment.
J'ai donc mis un message temporaire sur Facebook pour vous recruter,
pour ceux qui me suivent bien sûr sur Facebook,
pour les autres vous avez les liens dans la description.
Et j'ai demandé à Philippe Roche de participer pour pas que ce soit moi et que je reste en retrait du truc.
Les 6 personnes que vous allez voir participer,
qui sont des abonnés de la chaîne, se sont mis d'accord entre eux,
pour choisir qui allait mentir ou pas mentir.
Il va y avoir plusieurs histoires, Philippe va essayer de trouver
mais vous aussi évidemment, essayez de trouver qui est le menteur ou qui est la menteuse.
Salut aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu de vérité et de mensonges
où vous allez devoir déterminer si quelqu'un dit la vérité ou si quelqu'un ment.
Et il y a quelqu'un qui va essayer de le faire et live, c'est Philippe Roche et forcément il nous faut des cobayes:
Christen, Salomé, Paul, Jordan, Audrey et Natacha !
Ça va se passer en 2 étapes : pour la première étape, ils vont tous nous dire un souvenir de vacances sauf une personne qui va mentir...
Pour le premier essai, je ne vais pas vous donner de clé, et je te donne pas de clé à toi non plus.
Donc peut être que tu vas trouver, peut être que vous allez trouver aussi
ils vont tous dire en quelques mots un souvenir de vacances, SAUF une personne qui ment
mais on ne sait pas encore laquelle...
Christen: Il y a quelques mois de ça en février, je suis parti à New York
avec des amis.
Salomé: J'étais petite, j'avais environ 6 ans et je suis partie avec toute ma famille, donc mes parents, ma sœur et mon petit frère à Cuba.
Paul: En début d'année, je suis parti en échange universitaire et j'ai pu faire un voyage en Laponie
j'ai dormi dans une grotte de glace.
Jordan: J'ai gagné, grâce à un concours offert par l'armée, un baptême de l'air.
Audrey: L'an dernier pendant un voyage au Pérou j'ai nagé avec des lions de mer.
Natacha: A 13 ans, je suis partie à Mayotte, pendant 1 mois, toute seule.
Philippe: Tu peux me re-préciser les personnes qui étaient avec toi pendant tes vacances?
Salomé: Mes parents, ma grande soeur et mon petit frère.
Philippe: Ça ressemble à quoi un lion de mer ?
Audrey: C'est comme une otarie mais en plus gros.
Philippe: Par rapport aux buttes chaumont... comment c'était New York, c'était New York c'est ça ?
Christen: C'est ça.
Philippe: Central Park ça va?
Christen: Ah oui oui c'était bien, en février il neigeait en plus donc... oui
Fabien: Alors Philippe tu as posé des questions à tout le monde,
je pense que tu as un avis maintenant, je pense que vous aussi derrière votre écran vous avez un avis
d'après toi qui mentait ?
Philippe: Euh... alors pour moi c'est Audrey. Les lions de mer, les otaries...
je sais pas, j'ai un doute là-dessus.
Fabien: Est-ce que tu mentais ?
Audrey: Non. Je suis vraiment partie au Pérou et j'ai vraiment nagé avec des lions de mer.
Fabien: Est-ce que la personne qui mentait peut lever la main ?!
Fabien: Oui !  C'était Jordan
Jordan: Eh oui !
Fabien: Ce premier essai n'est pas une réussite pour Philippe,
peut être qu'il est une réussite pour vous
sauf que pour le deuxième essai Philippe, il va avoir une petite formation accélérée
c'est la page 97. Je te laisse ouvrir,
pour l'instant, eux, ils ne l'ont pas lu donc ils ne savent pas ce que ça va être, en fait, tes clés.
Je vous les donnerai à la fin les clés évidemment.
[musique]
Est-ce que tu te sens un peu plus armé ?
Philippe: Oh je vais les tuer !
*rires*
Fabien: Tu as intérêt à être bon parce que là tu viens de mettre la barre haute.
2ème essai, 2ème test aussi bien pour vous que pour Philippe.
Ce coup-ci ils vont tous vous raconter un truc de ouf qui leur est arrivé,
sauf une personne qui va mentir.
Christen: Quand je suis rentré de New York, du coup en avion, il y a eu une tempête de neige,
et je me suis retrouvé bloqué en Islande, alors que c'était pas prévu, une journée.
au fin fond de l'Islande dans un spa.
Dans un spa avec des aurores boréales c'était pas du tout prévu.
Salomé: Pour reprendre le contexte, du coup je suis toujours dans la piscine avec mon petit frère, ma famille et donc ma sœur
et donc on faisait un peu trop de bruit, on chahutait beaucoup avec mon frère
et ils se trouvent qu'on s'est disputé avec les petits enfants de Fidel Castro,
on les avait un peu trop éclaboussés.
Paul: Pareil, lors d'un voyage à Los Angeles, en voulant rentrer en avion
il y a eu une suspicion de détournement d'avion
donc on a été mis sur le tarmac pendant des heures avec intervention du FBI.
Fabien: Ce qui est génial c'est que c'est vraiment des trucs de ouf qu'ils te racontent !
Philippe: Et à tout moment Bruce Willis peut arriver.
Jordan: On est allé au festival de Cannes
et on a réussi à rentrer et à regarder un film alors qu'on avait pas de pass.
Audrey: Donc justement en parlant de lions de mer.
En allant à cette excursion-là, je me suis faite arrêtée par des flics
qui en fait m'ont escortée parce qu'avec mon ami on était sur le point de se faire racketter.
Philippe: Par une otarie.
*rires*
Natacha: J'étais à Paris. Et ma meilleure amie s'est fait draguer par Stéphane Plaza devant moi.
Fabien: Comme tout à l'heure Philippe va pouvoir poser des questions à un petit peu tout le monde.
Profitez-en vous aussi pour essayer d'affiner votre choix et savoir qui est le menteur ou la menteuse.
Philippe: Alors déjà je prendrai jamais l'avion avec la plupart d'entre eux...
*rires collectifs*
Philippe: Ça c'est la première des choses.
Pourquoi le FBI vous a fait descendre ou changer d'escale ?
Paul: En fait, on a pas changé d'escale. On est resté sur le tarmac pendant environ 10H.
Tout au bout de l'aéroport.
Philippe: Stéphane Plaza...
C'est où que ça s'est passé déjà ?
Natacha: C'était sur la ligne 1 du RER... du métro.
Philippe: Donc toi c'est une tempête de neige qui a provoqué le...
Christen: Parce qu'en fait on avait une escale très brève en Islande,
et à cause d'une tempête de neige on est resté bloqués toute une journée en fait.
Philippe: Tu partais de Paris?
Christen: Je rentrais de New York pour aller à Paris.
Philippe: Je sais pourquoi je me suis fait piéger sur le premier,
c'est justement la première règle de... de la page 97
Fabien: On va en profiter pour leur donner. C'était quoi la première règle de la page 97?
Philippe: Le regard fixe.
Fabien: Parce qu'il y a une légende urbaine qui dit qu'un menteur en fait regarde toujours un petit peu ailleurs.
En fait, c'est plutôt l'inverse.
Un menteur a tendance à regarder fixement la personne parce qu'elle a besoin de voir,
de valider que vous êtes en train d'avaler son mensonge
donc elle est en train de vous observer pour voir si vous êtes en train d'y croire
donc effectivement le regard fixe
est plus un signe de mensonge que de vérité.
Philippe: J'ai voulu jouer sur la distance.
Fabien: D'accord.
Philippe: Essayer de me raconter l'histoire à l'envers
donc j'ai fait exprès de demander si c'était bien une escale
mais du coup, il a pu me raconter assez facilement l'histoire
avec beaucoup de gestuelles.
Fabien: La gestuelle, on appelle ça "les illustrants". On en a tous plus ou moins et si on connait la base des illustrants d'une personne
on voit si y en a plus ou moins au fur et à mesure.
Par contre, le fait de raconter à l'envers - on en parle aussi dans le livre -
c'est déjà dur de raconter la vérité à l'envers donc alors mentir...
Philippe: Alors moi j'ai encore un doute sur le premier et le dernier récit.
Pour moi j'ai eu plus d'hésitations sur une histoire.... avec Natacha.
Donc je partirais plus sur Natacha.
Fabien: Est-ce que la personne qui mentait peut lever la main?
Philippe: Ah !
Fabien: Oui c'est Natacha.
*applaudissements*
Fabien: Est ce que t'avais déjà rencontré Stéphane Plaza ou tu as vraiment tout pipoté de A à Z ?
Natacha: C'est une histoire à moitié vraie. J'ai vraiment une copine qui s'est fait draguer par Stéphane Plaza mais j'étais pas là.
Fabien: Et peut être que vous aussi vous saviez que c'était Natacha
ou pas d'ailleurs.
En tout cas, c'est cool d'avoir vu qu'avec 2-3 clés
t'as pu voir quel était le souvenir fabriqué.
Alors peut être que vous aviez trouvé l'un des 2 ou les 2 ou aucun.
N'hésitez pas à me le dire dans les commentaires et à m'expliquer votre raisonnement.
Même si vous aviez faux, c'est aussi intéressant de voir les mauvais raisonnements
parce que des fois ça peut partir sur une bonne piste
et on peut expliquer ça.
On a parlé plusieurs fois d'un chapitre sur le mensonge qu'il y a dans le livre
mais j'ai aussi fait des vidéos sur le mensonge.
N'hésitez pas justement à le taper dans la barre de recherche, vous allez le retrouver.
Très rapidement un grand merci à Christen, à Salomé, à Paul, à Jordan,
à Audrey et à Natacha qui se sont rendus disponibles et qui sont venus participer à cette vidéo.
Un grand merci , également, à Philippe Roche.
Il a aussi une chaîne Philippe Roche.
Je vous mets le lien dans la description
et surtout un grand merci à vous
un 500 000 fois Merci !
Merci d'être ici certes, mais aussi merci parce que depuis quelques semaines
les vidéos sont souvent dans les tendances,
alors qu'on n'est pas sur des titres en majuscule, ou putaclic, ou avec des vignettes chelous
et ça c'est vraiment grâce à vous.
La dernière, elle était même première des tendances.
Merci beaucoup.
Comme d'habitude si vous avez aimé vous pouvez liker, commenter, partager, vous abonner
Tchao !
[musique]